it's time for a pick from the little
yellow book which is my personal guide
to things i think will make your life
even better and today it's an out of
this world book from our favorite
intergalactic gal please welcome elisa
kelly
thank you
[Applause]
elisa and i have been doing this show
since week one and your new book takes
us back to basics it's like an astrology
handbook
yeah i so for this book i really wanted
to
tell stories i wanted to tell my story i
wanted to tell my clients stories
because what i have discovered in the
years that i have been doing this is
that we are all so connected and by
learning about other people and their
trials and tribulations and their
successes and weaknesses we can really
see ourselves in their narratives so
hopefully this book will inspire people
to take a closer look at their own story
i love that well we have you here and
you know we're obsessed is there any way
we could get a reading oh my goodness
okay of course tell us everything i want
to know of course everything what's
happening in the world
what are we in for
okay so for the rest of 2021 there's a
lot of really good things to look
forward to we do have mercury retrograde
when
in october our first half of october so
mercury retrograde is when the planet of
communication starts going backwards
however it's important to remember it's
an optical illusion it is not actually
going backwards so maybe the things that
seem a little messy are not actually
that messy it's just that we need to
shift our perspective in order to see
them from a different point of view so
we have mercury retrograde we have lots
of beautiful moons we have new moons we
have full moons we have eclipses so the
rest of 2021 is going to really deliver
it's going to be very magical and we
just had a harvest moon yeah we did two
days ago yes
now you just did um a digital piece with
tom green in our digital room and he
told me that you told him something that
freaked me out about the age of aquarius
is this accurate yes all right well
you're gonna have to go to our digital
feed on the drewberrymart show.com where
eliza kelly is going to tell tom green
the myth of the age of the aquarius and
when i found out about it my jaw dropped
so thank you elisa kelly congratulations
[Applause]
this is your destiny using astrology to
manifest your best life thank you very
empowering all right take some of this
good energy take it with you for the
rest of the day everybody who chose to
come here today thank you so much and
anybody who may be watching at home or
on the go
thank you thank you thank you and have a
fantastic day elisa it's better right
than year one yes this is amazing
[Applause]
[Music]